hello and welcome to this video play
toys r us and see do now yeah I'm not so
much in for Kings Indian again he s and
we have those quite um and sharp Kings
Indians usually where i tend to have
good positions just screws him up
somehow so I'm switching to a trump
something else sorry about my voice too
much talking today okay so he's gifting
me apart that's nice I'll take it I'd
absolutely take it okay um if I take
with the night he has be too and he has
also if I've as a possible move so I'll
take with the pawn and it's not a
completely unclear situation now that
that that porn because um it's not
easily protected him and f3 is not a
move that fit so well so how to play
this just with these III and continue to
develop let's do that I also want to be
quick here it's usually a quick player
and tricky player so bad score also
Bishop d7 oh yeah I don't know what this
does
I just don't know and so I got rid of
that that's not not bad of the double
porn I'd you never three is making some
kind of sense here okay he wants to porn
back badly okay um if I take their he's
got the check Oh always yeah I again and
I'm getting behind on time check
and I should just play moose okay we
should f6e might play Quincy form
I wanted to play with sugar 6 now you
have to do that just keep c4 protected
and III as well
yeah I think I should be a bit better
because spaceship takes f6 is somewhat
annoying if I can play it and I don't
see how he avoids it 27 s is bad 26 also
yeah my development is not great other
than that my position is very good
threatens Knight f6 wins winning a pawn
it's not such a big deal that pawn maybe
but rookie one is good anyway so ok
Knight b6 he had Queen before but I was
reading this now 9 p-6 ok take stuff I'm
taking material him I Quincy five maybe
as possible and I is a tricky guy tricky
player
night a eight Bishop c4 it's not clear
that this is great okay and I take him
and that was a pretty bad pretty bad
transformation the night I shouldn't
give her ever but I the way it went i
had to sew night to be force may be
coming okay I'll and I'll cover that
porn let the King do something useful
now it's quite a typical movie place
very active moves always sometimes I
don't feel a very solid francs for
example here I think this is more
hurting him than it does hurt and hurt
me but ok we'll see if I have an f5 of a
pretty reach now
okay so if i just go back to f1 and i'm
not sure if that's it's so great between
be true we will take that again too slow
I know that it looks actor what he has
but his structure is completely wrecked
so unless he gets something with this
active pieces he's just in bad shape yo
he has just read pawns for every pawn
this week so we'll see what happens here
you can take the one of course Teague's
and then queen here getting it back this
is the moment where he needs some kind
of Jack Jack doesn't seem to be existing
check so I'm just playing this position
now and have I have the better structure
hi morning so I just have to avoid
blundering stuff okay check check check
oya k that is pretty active it's pretty
active Air Force probably a bad idea and
it's not so easy jack check-check wanted
to not give him too many passes but it's
okay now he can probably help perpetual
here this is actually risky a little bit
check
check check all right killed William
good check check Dragic offered draw
offered draw offered game dry out it's a
draw yeah it was a bit so it's not
enough actually have that positive that
out of that position but time management
got to me around here I have very good
chances and because of the much better
structure and here he gave away that so
on but I working it to let the side
that's a bit some miss this is a lot
better that he has to for that he is
forced to play you form and then
something like this that's a very good
position or take the pawn I mean I can
also take you on and check it activates
his King though it's not entirely clear
that's not so clear maybe it's really
better to to go here and keep impassive
this kind of thing yeah I win the pawn
anyway he have excellent winning chances
yeah the biggest thing is um check okay
I didn't need to give the porn back but
ok here oh yeah I could have taken f6
okay I was pretty good yeah it is very
good of course okay I castled ok Knight
b6 is bad move yeah it's really a bad
move because this is keeping things
together king of towards probably we had
all 94 is a nice short very nice and
black as a lot better yeah King f2 it
was a somewhat we had moved but I felt I
can really use my king summer yeah Here
I am ok and didn't gain he should just
avoid head and he must avoid queen dee 5
ok it's better for one anyway now with
two porn islands against four so he has
some some problems here ok at the end
the draw thanks for watching